I mean nobody gives you a pill you know
it's like alright you're a civilian
again forget everything you learned as a
Marine and go incorporate yourself into
society and act normal you know and for
me what's normal so before Zoe it was
just a lot of I kept to myself a lot in
this case I feel like I rescued her and
she rescued me
before I had lady she it I hardly got
out of the house I would stay in the
house for days
from day one she knew I was having panic
or anxiety she would just keep pawing me
so at first I was wondering why are you
keep white keep calling me and then then
I figured it out if I can barely take
care of myself
how do I take care of another animal
fortunately those thoughts quickly
disappeared as soon as I got into this
program here at RF we pair shelter dogs
with veterans where they're originally
emotional support animals these veterans
are then encouraged to come back and
continue training with us to train their
dogs to be their service dogs our
rescues all our dogs from municipal
shelters that are bulging at the seams
with dogs
I mean sadly many of them might be put
down it's hard to know exactly what
would happen one of the biggest things
with PTSD for me being out in public was
hard I could never have my back towards
an exit you know I was felt unsafe one
thing I never thought I'd be able to do
before Zoey was incorporate myself back
into society into the regular civilian
world
next time you're getting freaked out
really observe yourself I guess is the
last thing I'm a mom
[Laughter]
[Music]
when I was in the Marine Corps what I
loved about it was the camaraderie that
we had with my fellow brothers and
sisters as soon as I got Zoey it felt
like she was my little marine you know
so I had a little mentee again you know
and I was very mentor so everyday
training gave me a schedule it basically
like said hey Mike you got to buck up
you got to act right because I have
another living being to take care of Dog
Chow is spreading the word that programs
like ours exist so thanks to dog chow
and it's made my life with Zoey so much
easier and Karina surprised us with food
through the program and that's been a
huge help there's the stigma from some
people that shelter dogs may be damaged
in some way and they're not they're just
dogs that weren't given a fair shake and
I'm a veteran myself and sometimes I
would feel that way in some way I was
damaged and when it comes to this
program we're helping both sides we're
helping the dogs were helping the people
and together they're helping each other
she's came a long way so now that I have
Zoey it's like it's like a bond I can't
you're not gonna break you know it's
like a best friend thank you for helping
me I'm proud of you T I tell me that
every day Zoey I love you
[Music]